in this episode of street talk unplugged
and so one thing that i find fascinating
is that there is absolutely no reason
why this should work like at all there
is nothing that we can observe that says
that these kinds of rules should exist
at all this this model in principle is
it's like it's too simple for it to
actually work
welcome back to street talk
this week we are coming live from lisbon
in portugal i haven't had access to my
studio or any of my uh you know normal
recording equipment so it's going to be
a bit of an interesting one but i've
been working out of coffee shops
building an introduction doing all my
stuff so yeah it's going to be a show
about strong and weak emergence
about cellular automata and we're going
to be interviewing dr danielle gratarola
and speaking all about his work on graph
cellular automata so i hope you enjoy it
folks
see you soon
one thing that really fascinates me is
um a lot of the interesting phenomena
happens at a different level a different
rung of the emergence ladder if that
makes sense and i'm starting to see this
everywhere like even at work i'm
building a code review platform and at
the low level the metrics are obvious
i know ken talks about the uh the
tyranny of metrics by the way but you
know it's how many code reviews that has
an engineer done how many customer
engineers do i have it's easy and then i
start going up the levels of abstraction
i'm talking to the senior leaders and
now i'm starting to use much more
abstract language like vertical
information flows and trust and
engineering culture
and all of a sudden it's impossible for
me to quantify and if i do i'm making it
up and it's the same thing
you're talking about these population
scale phenomena that happen now so i've
got all of these intelligent agents
they're doing things and and i can try
and because now i've got a meta
optimization problem right so i want to
encourage interesting phenomena
in the emergent scale so i might say
well this type of thing is interesting i
want more of that but i'm i'm kind of
i'm reaching because i don't know how to
describe it i mean i think one other one
other characteristic you can point to
that that kind of separates um like
population from just individual is
sort of specialization versus
generalization like i think population
driven algorithms sort of
implicitly are more about specialization
a lot of the time because like each
member of the population you want to be
doing some different thing
so they're kind of becoming specialists
but i think there's a huge amount of
generalization snobbery kind of within
machine learning like we're looking for
the ultimate general list all the time
it's like get it to do all the tasks you
can possibly do and then throw more in
and the data set just gets bigger and
we're all very impressed with that the
population implies i feel like
something's in spirit different because
it's more just like
actually i want to see a lot of
different things and like hyper
specializations to all kinds of exotic
things that like probably the generals
won't do because it's basically all
cares about is being general this comes
down to like the focus on like the
particular level of abstraction or the
level of agency that we have professor
melanie mitchell wrote a beautiful book
on complexity about 10 years ago i hope
one day we can get it back on the
podcast and discuss it in detail in the
book she led with a quote from john
locke
i call complex
such as our beauty gratitude a man
an army
the universe
the animal kingdom has several examples
of what i would call externalized or
collective intelligence
melanie quote biologist nigel franks in
her book
the solitary army ant is behaviorally
one of the least sophisticated animals
imaginable
if 100 army ants are placed on a flat
surface
they will walk around and around in
never decreasing circles until they die
of exhaustion
yet if you put half a million of them
together the group as a whole becomes
what some have called a super organism
with collective intelligence
the whole is in some sense more than the
sum of its parts although we need to be
quite careful with the language that we
use here
an emergent behavior or emergent
property can appear when a number of
simple entities or agents operate in an
environment forming more complex
behaviors as a collective
if emergence happens over disparate size
scales then the reason is usually a
causal relation between different scales
western science has a strong tendency
towards reductionism because it assumes
that things have essences so science
keeps chopping up things into smaller
and smaller pieces to find their essence
it's an intellectual and philosophical
position which interprets a complex
system as the sum of its parts
this is in stark contrast with
relationism which you could say is
related to the philosophical ideas we
were discussing with andrew lampanen
from deepmind last week
biologist peter corning asserted that
this whole discussion rather misses the
point
he said that holes produce unique
combined effects but many of these
effects may be co-determined by the
context and the interactions between the
whole and its environments
now weak emergence describes new
properties arising in systems as a
result of low-level interactions these
might be interactions between components
of the system or components and their
environment
emerging properties are scale dependent
though and can only be observed at large
enough system scale one reason emergent
behavior is hard to predict is that the
number of interactions between a
system's components increases
exponentially with the number of
components thus allowing for many new
and subtle types of behavior to emerge
emergence is often a product of
particular patterns of interaction
negative feedback introduces constraints
that serve to fix structures or
behaviors in contrast positive feedback
promotes change allowing local
variations to grow into global patterns
on the other hand merely having a large
number of interactions is not enough by
itself to guarantee emergent behavior
many of the interactions may be
negligible or irrelevant or may cancel
each other out in some cases a large
number of interactions can in fact
hinder the emergence of interesting
behavior by creating a lot of noise to
drown out any emerging signal
the system has to reach a combined
threshold of diversity organization and
connectivity before emergent behavior
appears
mark bedau said in his 1999 paper titled
weak emergence that an innocent form of
emergence what he called weak emergence
is now commonplace in the thriving
interdisciplinary nexus of scientific
activity sometimes called the sciences
of complexity interestingly which he
elected to put in air quotes for some
reason
he said that this included connectionist
modelling and non-linear dynamics which
is now commonly known as chaos theory
and indeed artificial life
he gave two interesting hallmarks of
emergent phenomena in his opinion
one emergent phenomena are somehow
constituted by
and generated from
an underlying process
and two
emergent phenomena are somehow
autonomous from the underlying process
so he said that emergence is a perennial
philosophical puzzle and at best the
idea raises the spectre of
illegitimately getting something from
nothing
he said that any defense of emergence
should aim to explain that is to say
explain away
the apparent illegitimate metaphysics
and indeed demonstrate emergence to be
entirely compatible with materialism
he argued that emergence must be more
than intellectual masturbation putting
words in his mouth here and actually
demonstrate tangible value to the
empirical sciences and be a constructive
player in our understanding of the
natural world
he argued that weak emergence meets
these goals but argued that stronger
forms of emergence are entirely
irrelevant
he said that the failings of strong
emergence can be traced back to this
idea of strong downward causation which
is this notion that things in the lower
resolution emergent domain can cause
things in the high resolution domain
mark said that strong emergence is
uncomfortably like magic
how does a super veniant but irreducibly
downward causal power arise since by
definition it cannot be the result of
the high resolution domain he said this
would discomfort reasonable forms of
materialism and pay homage to the idea
that it's possible to get something from
nothing
mark concluded by saying that strong
emergence is just a mystery which we
don't need
it's interesting to note that his
definition of weak emergence is as
follows
macro state p of s with micro dynamic d
is weakly emergent if and only if p can
be derived from d
and s is external conditions but only by
simulation so interestingly his
definition incorporates the necessity
for computational irreducibility but not
the notion of whether it is effectively
computable
one of the main hallmarks of weak
emergence is the underrivability except
for finite simulation the exponential
divergence of trajectories or indeed the
so-called butterfly effect describing
the sensitivity of a physical simulation
on its starting parameters is a
well-known feature of chaotic systems
but mark says that weak emergence is
present in almost all complex systems
regardless of whether they produce
chaotic dynamics which lead to weak
emergence being part of the definition
of what it means to be a complex system
the popular physics youtuber dr sabine
hossenfelder wrote a paper called the
case for strong emergence she felt that
weak emergence was too deterministic and
a front on free will if you like
she used to think that we're all made of
tiny particles which follow strict laws
and human behavior is really just a
consequence of these particles laws
needless to say she's since changed her
mind and she thinks that you should as
well
she led by saying reductionism works
large things are made of smaller things
and if you know what the smaller things
do you know what the larger things do
physicists call this idea reductionism
now you might not like it but it works
pretty well arguably reductionism
allowed us to understand molecular bonds
and chemical elements atomic fission and
fusion the behavior of an atom's
constituents and the constituents of
those constituents and whoever knows
what the physicist will come up with
next she said
she admits that the best explanation for
the world around us right now is almost
certainly incomplete
sabine decided to discuss the concept of
emergence in respect to physical
theories and how fundamental they are
she said that a physical theory is a set
of mathematically consistent axioms
combined with an identification of some
of the theory's mathematical structures
with observables
if two physical theories give the same
predictions for all possible observables
then they are physically equivalent
she displayed a figure depicting a
directed graph of physical theories an
edge between two theories meant that one
was more fundamental than the other
she said that a physical theory a is
more fundamental than b if b can be
derived from a but not the other way
around
in this case the theory b is weakly
emergent from a
a physical theory is fundamental if it
is to the best current knowledge not
emergent from any other theory so this
is quite interesting weekly emergent is
the opposite of more fundamental the
idea that the theory at low resolution
is always weakly emergent it can be
derived at least in principle from the
theory at high resolution
sabine also discussed the causal
exclusion argument which roughly
speaking says that if a lower resolution
effect can be derived from a theory at
high resolution then the effect cannot
have another cause the causal exclusion
argument combined with effective field
theory is the main reason why physicists
believe that reductionism is correct and
in a sense why strong emergence is not a
thing
she also spoke about top-down causation
which is this idea that the laws of a
system at low resolution can dictate the
laws at high resolution
a good example of this is the mental
states in our brain causing our bodies
to perform physical actions
so it's important not to think of the
emergent layers as being independent or
assuming that they could or should be
modeled in isolation interestingly
though in sabine's article she denied
that top-down causation even exists at
all
in her conclusion sabine did a 180
degrees and she decided that in fact
there are many examples where there
isn't a clear effective computational or
functional path between physical
theories she gave a hypothetical example
of a function which cannot be computed
for negative values of x or a taylor
series expansion around zero and she
said that if there are any points where
the coupling can't be continued between
resolutions you'll need new initial
values which would need to be determined
by measurement and therefore strong
emergence is viable
she said it's only fair on philosophers
who believe that strong emergence exists
that physicists first show the coupling
constraints of a quantum field theory
can always be continued to low energies
for physically realistic systems
so what is emergence emergence is just
the interpretation of a phenomenon from
the perspective of a different scale at
least according to professor david
chalmers
he wrote a paper called strong and weak
emergence where he lamented the abuse of
the term strong emergence by complex
systems scientists and cognitive
scientists echoing mark badal before him
chalmers says that it is strong
emergence which is most common in the
philosophical parlance of emergence and
in particular used by the british
emergentists of the 1920s he thought
that we could say a high-level
phenomenon is strongly emerging with
respect to a low-level domain when the
high-level domain phenomenon arises from
the low level domain but truths
concerning that phenomenon are not
deducible even in principle from truths
in the low level domain
now i think deducible is a bit of a
weasel word but we'll talk more about
that in a minute um he says that weak
emergence does not yield the same sort
of radical metaphysical expansion in our
conception of the world as strong
emergence but it's no less interesting
he says that you can think of weak
emergence in terms of the ease of
understanding of one level in terms of
another level
emergent properties are usually
properties which are more easily
understood in their own right than in
terms of properties at a lower level
indicating that weak emergence appears
to be an observer relative property
now how interesting is this high level
phenomenon to an observer and how
difficult is it to deduce this
phenomenon from the lower level that is
emergence
so chalmers takes emergence in the
general sense to mean surprising or
interesting and indeed an unexpected
phenomena and he uses the strong versus
weak designation to delineate a radical
paradigmatic surprise
he says that the emergence of high-level
patterns and cellular automata a
paradigm of emergence in recent complex
systems theory provides a clear example
if one is given only basic rules
governing a cellular automaton then the
formation of complex high-level patterns
such as gliders may well be unexpected
therefore the patterns are weakly
emerging but the formation of those
patterns is straightforwardly deducible
from the rules and the initial
conditions
he concedes that this might take a fair
amount of computation
which he indicates as a reason why the
emergent behavior wasn't obvious to
start with and i assume by the word
obvious he's kind of
means as an autonym to unexpected
cellular automata are provably
computationally irreducible this means
that there are no analytical shortcuts
to perform the effective calculation
without resorting to running the
sequential simulation in its entirety
since the computational domain is
exponentially large in the case of
discrete cellular automata and
infinitely large in the case of
continuous cellular automata if you were
trying to find the initial conditions
and rules for a given behavior or even
if you had to recompute the simulation
we would argue that this constitutes at
least a semi-strong designation of
emergence because of the effective
computability right the effective
computability must come into it
professor chalmers says that strong
emergence has much more radical
consequences than weak emergence if
there are phenomena that are strongly
emergent with respect to the domain of
physics then our conception of the
natural world would need to be
revolutionized to accommodate them with
new fundamental theories
now i find this a little bit strange i
mean given that a class iv cellular
automata is touring incomplete which is
to say that they can represent any
computer program it seems like a
contentious point that there's no
possible output in a cellular automata
which would be paradigmatically
surprising maybe i'm wrong
to be clear chalmers is a materialist
right he's not subscribing to any kooky
views by saying this he's a
computationalist in the sense that he
agrees that if he replicated him atom by
atom in the natural world according to
our universe then it would have a
consciousness right but he argues that
consciousness isn't a logical necessity
he could imagine a universe which has
all the same physical laws where he
would be a philosophical zombie because
it's not logically necessary yeah so
this term emergence is you know it's so
woolly and uh
ambiguous i mean it gets used for so
many different things
uh in the sciences in philosophy any
kind of phenomenon of a complex system
that we don't fully understand we say oh
yeah well it's emergent and then okay
well great well what's the cash value of
uh of that and i've found it useful to
distinguish as you were weak and strong
emergence where weak emergence is kind
of a matter of mostly of complexity
um where for example you've got some
simple rules at the bottom level that
gives rise to some high level
macroscopic phenomenon
which is complex and surprising
hard to predict and derive as a
practical matter
but it's really more of a practical
limitation you can still see in
principle why those bottom level
principles say laws of physics or
rules in a cellular automaton would in
principle give rise to these high-level
phenomena derivable and principle if not
in practice whereas strong emergence
would require something that's not even
derivable in principle and i guess i
think that most of the things you get in
ai or
complex systems theory and so on involve
weak emergence certainly i was very
influenced by um
doug hofstadter here who's
who's you know good alicia bark is in
some ways all about the powers of weak
emergence how
really
simple processes at one level could give
you complex processes
at a higher level and actually get these
tangled hierarchies he'd talk or strange
loops you'd go up a few levels and then
you'd you'd come down so i guess i'm
probably more sympathetic with
hofstadter's picture of weak emergence
than say george ellis's where causation
is always within a level i think there
are very complex relations between the
levels and some of them may be best
understood as causal you could think of
it you know the butterfly
um
snapping its wings having some causal
relation to some sociological event days
later so you do get these
tangled hierarchies but all that is
still weak emergence
so he's agreeing with mark badal by
saying that any endorsement of strong
emergence is a rejection of physicalism
and reductionism which is to say an
appeal to magic and esoterica
whereas weak emergence can be used to
support the physicalist picture of the
world by showing how all sorts of
phenomena which might seem novel and
irreducible at first sight can
nevertheless be grounded in underlying
simple physical laws
chalmers thinks that there is exactly
one clear example of strong emergence in
our universe which is guess what our
consciousness
[Music]
we can say that a system is conscious
when there is something it is like to be
that system which is to say it has a
phenomenological experience
chalmers argues that it is a fact of
nature that the universe contains
conscious systems we are existence
proofs of that and there's reason to
believe that the facts about
consciousness are not deducible from any
number of physical facts it makes the
argument that there could be a world
physically identical to this one but
lacking consciousness entirely which is
very similar to that philosophical
zombies argument that i just spoke about
or even containing conscious experiences
which are potentially different to our
own roger penrose said that the human
ability to understand is undecidable and
requires consciousness
if this is true it might be a
mathematical proof that consciousness is
strongly emergent exactly as charm as
claims
and so
the way i the way i view strong
emergence at least for for right now is
that if i have these different
formalizations at different levels
and it's just not possible in any
practical
scheme whatsoever for me to directly
go from
a lower level to a higher level like for
example i just can't computationally do
it or there's
no mathematics that can ever hope to
symbolically you know prove that that uh
the properties i observe at a higher
level derive from a lower level
maybe i you know people say well in
principle you could but in reality you
just may never be able to do that you
know does that qualify as strong
emergence or is that a bad definition of
it and do you think there is such a
thing as strongly emergent behavior or
can we ultimately just reduce everything
down to
uh hypergraph or or loop chrom quantum
gravity or whatever
every level a sense is independent you
cannot expect it to be fully reduced to
a lower one or okay a higher one
or each level has its own value it has
its
concepts it has these conclusions it has
problems that's suitable to be to be
solved at the level not higher or lower
that is
to me that's the first principle but the
second one is you don't want to push it
too far you don't want to say all the
layers have nothing to do with each
other
so as after all we're talking about the
same object okay we're talking about the
same that the google map of the same eye
area even though you zoom in block out a
different level if he is
a two map a different array that's a
different story okay so as far as all
those theories
is in a sense about the same object but
there is the different levels of
description
and they are correlated but they are
kind of like
very overall high level uh
not high level is the wrong way to say
it is confusing
the relation it's kind of like you have
a overall
large scale
correlation
but you don't have one-to-one mapping
among the concepts that's also my
opinion about the relation for example
between neurons and concepts
uh of course they're related but there
is no one to unmapping or if not even
money problem might be
it's more like a money to mine in my
opinion and also it's very messy in my
opinion
uh except if you want to limit your
discussion
to a very special phenomena at a certain
level for example we know that some
basic concepts in chemistry
can be explained very well in physics
right
because villains talk about the details
uh the same story of something in
biology can be explained very well with
physics and chemistry we should talk
about the details
so that's true but on the other hand if
you say that
biology overall can be even truly
reduced it to chemistry and uh feelings
i say not only that's practically wrong
is even theoretically wrong
because when you're seeing that
you're ignoring
the
cognitive capability
of the researcher
and the user of your theory you cannot
really reduce everything
to
uh to the to the lower level without
greatly increase the number of concepts
right computational cost
melanie mitchell pointed out that it's
incredibly mysterious how the intricate
machinery of the immune system fights
disease or how a group of cells
organizes itself to be an eye or a brain
or how independent members of an economy
each working chiefly for their own gain
produce complex but structured global
markets
or most mysteriously how the phenomena
we call intelligence or consciousness
emerge from non-intelligent
non-conscious material substrates
the cognitive scientist douglas
hofstadter in his book go to lescherbach
made an extended analogy between ant
colonies and brains both being complex
systems in which relatively simple
components with only limited
communication among themselves
collectively give rise to complicated
and sophisticated system-wide global
behavior
the ants in our human brain are of
course our neurons they communicate with
each other in a similarly simplistic
manner yet our intelligence and arguably
our consciousness emerge from this
low-level primitive communication
markets are also complex emergent and
self-organizing entities if you like
melanie said in her book that they are
self-organized on the microscopic and
the macroscopic level she said that on
the microscopic level individuals and
companies and markets try to increase
their profitability by learning about
the behavior of other individuals and
companies
the microscopic self-interest has
historically thought to push markets as
a whole on the macroscopic level towards
a so-called nash equilibrium
now the process by which markets obtain
this equilibrium is called the market
efficiency
the 18th century economist adam smith
called this self-organizing behavior of
markets the invisible hand
it arises from the myriad microscopic
actions of individual buyers and sellers
the individual actions on a trading
floor give rise to the hard to predict
large-scale behavior of financial
markets
now melanie gives three core properties
of complex systems in her book
one
complex collective behavior
large networks of individual components
which each one following relatively
simple rules with no central control or
leader it's the collective action of
vast numbers of components that give
rise to the complex hard to predict and
changing patterns of behavior which
fascinate us so much
[Music]
two
signaling and information processing
complex systems use information and
signals from both their internal and
external environments
and three
adaptation all of these systems adapt
that is they change their behavior to
improve their chances of survival or
success through learning or some
evolutionary process
so melanie then goes on to give her
definition of a complex system as
follows
a system in which a large network of
components with no central control and
simple rules of operation give rise to
complex collective behavior
sophisticated information processing and
adaptation by learning or evolution
now i spoke with our friend dr duggar on
strong emergence and he said that in his
opinion it describes behaviors which
cannot be analytically derived nor
effectively computed from a lower level
or higher resolution theory this would
place glider wars in a cellular
automaton firmly in the domain of strong
emergence
a cellular automaton is computationally
irreducible there's no effective
computational path from the lower level
rules to the higher level behavior the
only thing you can do is run the
simulation again from scratch
he thought that chalmers and
hossenfelder evade the issue and or beg
the question by phrases like deducible
in principle or a fair amount of
computation or follows from that at
least in principle etcetera etcetera so
you know what he's saying is that they
make claims which
we can in principle do something but
they can't actually demonstrate or
perform with a reasonable amount of
computation
in physical strong emergence you can't
even run the computation at least in a
continuous cellular automaton you're
pretty much in the same boat as the end
body problem
now a lot of this discussion comes down
to whether you believe infinity exists
or not actual infinity this is a teaser
clip from our conversation with dr
joshua bach
can the universe can our actual universe
that we're in right now
be actually infinite in spatial extent
the problem is that you can have
unboundedness in the sense that you have
a computation that doesn't stop giving
you results
but you cannot take the last result of
such a computation and go to the next
step
you cannot have a computation that
relies on knowing the last digit of pi
before it goes to the next step in this
sense you don't have an infinity but the
infinities are about the conclusion of
such a function it means that you
actually run this function to the end
and then do something with the result
unboundedness is different in the sense
that you will always get something new
that you didn't expect that you cannot
predict but it's it's just going on and
on without this end and it i think it's
completely conceivable that our universe
is in this class of systems in the sense
that it doesn't end
but
it doesn't mean that there is anything
that gives you the result of an infinite
computation because if that was the case
then it could not be expressed in any
language
it also means if something cannot be
expressed in any language that you
cannot actually properly think about it
because when you think you need to think
in some kind of language not in english
but in some kind of language of sort or
in a mathematical language that doesn't
have contradictions and what girdle has
shown is that the language that he hoped
to reason in about infinities
breaks that it has contradictions in it
that at some point it blows blows itself
apart so the languages that we can build
are only those in which we have to
assume that infinities cannot be built
so infinity in this sense is meaningless
because we cannot make it in any kind of
language
so the thing is though i'm not limiting
what the universe is capable of based on
human you know mental and linguistic
limitations or even mathematical
limitations like i'm i'm asking you if
it's possible for this universe that
we're in to anticly be right now
actually infinite in spatial extent
the thing is that you try to make a
reference to something that you cannot
observe and cannot conceive of other
than making a model in some kind of
language
and to have that model make sense the
language needs to work right otherwise
you are just
maybe in some kind of delusional thing
you can't get to infinity from
non-infinity and you can't get to
discrete from analog so keith believes
that there are actual infinities in
stark contrast to people like stephen
wolfram but our brains are
computationally bound we are conducting
what is a discrete computation in our
mind but we might have access to oracles
which is to say we're connected to a
turing machine but we can only sample at
a certain rate
keith believes in infinity therefore
there may be many strongly emergent
phenomena because they're not computable
he therefore doesn't think the universe
can even run on a computer or indeed
that we exist inside a simulation
the simplest way to prove the
constructivist hypothesis that natural
systems need to perform computation in
order to succeed and adapt in respect of
its environment is to create an
idealized version of the problem that is
to say let's simplify it as much as
possible while still retaining the
features that make the problem
interesting and that is exactly what a
cellular automaton does
cellular automata are a class of
computational models that exhibit rich
dynamics weakly emerging from the local
interactions of cells arranged on a
regular lattice for example
two-dimensional grid
cellular automata were invented by john
von neumann back in the 1940s they
exhibit extremely complex behavior
that's difficult or impossible to
predict from the cell update rule
now melanie mitchell commented in her
book that this is one of the great
ironies of computer science
since cellular automata often referred
to as non von neumann style
architectures in contrast with the von
neumann style architectures
that he also invented
von neumann was also able to show that
his cellular automaton was equivalent to
a universal turing machine
and therefore capable of universal
computation which is to say computing
anything which a turing machine can
in 1970 john conway invented his own
cellular automata called the game of
life and it had significantly simpler
update rules than von neumann's version
the most simple version is on a 2d grid
with discrete binary values where the
alive or dead state of every single cell
depends on its eight neighboring cells
the rules are as follows
one
any live cell with two or three live
neighbors
survives
two
any dead cell with three live neighbors
becomes a live cell
three all other live cells die in the
next generation similarly all of the
dead cells
stay dead
even though the game of life doesn't
pretend to be the most sophisticated way
to understand complex systems they are a
wonderfully simple way to get acquainted
in the ideas of complexity science and
in particular weak emergence
now many of the patterns are incredibly
lifelike and that's because these are
class four automata they are touring
complete which is to say they're capable
of representing any computation
now being weakly emergent doesn't
preclude useful analysis i mean for
example it's still possible to model how
frequently phenomena like gliders appear
in the emergent domain given many random
initializations
laws governing the weakly emergent
states almost certainly exist but can
only be discovered through empirical
analysis and observation and simulation
we can identify motifs
systems behaviors mechanisms
high level abstractions even in the
emergent layer but nothing from first
principles in what sense do natural
systems compute
at a very general level one might say
that computation is what a complex
system does with information in order to
succeed or adapt in its environment
morphogenesis means the generation of
form
it's colloquially described in a
biological process that causes a cell or
a tissue or an organism to develop its
shape but in an artificial intelligence
context we can think of it as meaning
the blueprint of emergence of any
physical form
professor sebastian riese recently wrote
an article called the future of
artificial intelligence is
self-organizing and self-assembling and
before you ask yes we'll be inviting him
to mlst
he spoke of a current movement which
combines ideas from deep learning with
ideas from self-organization and
collective systems it's a wonderful tree
ties for emergentist open-ended and
biologically inspired ai enthusiasts
searching for parameters of
self-organizing systems which produce
particular patterns is a difficult
optimization problem
trying to make self-organization
programmable is a research field of its
own called morphogenetic engineering he
said that the merger of these ideas
could ultimately allow our ai systems to
escape their current limitations such as
being brittle and rigid and not being
able to deal with novel situations
however the combination of these methods
also poses new challenges and requires
novel ways of training to work as
efficiently as possible
risi said that one of the most
fascinating aspects of nature is that
groups with millions or even trillions
of elements can self-assemble into
complex forms based only on local
interactions and display what is called
a collective type of intelligence
sebastian gave the example of ants which
can join forces to create bridges and
rafts or navigate difficult terrain
termites can build nests several meters
high without an externally imposed plan
and thousands of bees work together as
an integrated whole to make accurate
decisions on when to search for food or
a new nest
he said that achieving these incredible
abilities is a result of following
relatively simple behavioral rules
through a process of self-organization
kamazin
defined self-organization in 2001 as the
following
as a process in which a pattern at the
global level of a system emerges solely
from the numerous interactions among
lower level components of the system
moreover the rules specifying
interactions among the systems
components are executed using only local
information without reference to the
global pattern
in short the pattern is an emergent
property of the system rather than being
imposed on the system by an external
ordering influence
with the emergence of powerful machine
learning algorithms sebastian said that
the key question is instead of hand
designing the algorithms for
self-assembly can we learn these
algorithms instead allowing more complex
forms to be created
sebastian said that self-organizing
systems are made out of many components
which are highly interconnected the
absence of any centralized control
allows them to quickly adjust to new
stimuli and changing environmental
conditions additionally because these
collective intelligence systems are made
of many simpler individuals they have
built-in redundancy with a high degree
of resilience and robustness
individuals in this collective system
can fail without the overall system
breaking down
sebastian points out that evolution was
able to exploit self-organizational
processes to create artifacts of
remarkable complexity however
human-made designs are normally put
together piece by piece this is similar
to the idea of whether an ai
architecture and knowledge should be
human engineered or revolved blank slate
style such as professor rich sutton
pointed out in his bitter lesson essay
the amount of information it takes to
specify the wiring of a sophisticated
brain directly is far greater than the
information stored in the genome instead
of storing a specific configuration of
synapses the genome encodes a much
smaller number of rules that govern how
to wire up a brain through
self-organizing processes and how
synapses should change based on the
activation of neurons this amazing
compression has also been called the
genomic bottleneck
now when humans engineer bridges or
teach curricula there's always a plan a
pedagogy a curriculum
in biological construction there's no
blueprint well not one which defines the
outcome evolution is a kind of meta
optimizer and our dna is incredibly
compressed it can't possibly describe
the complex configuration of our brains
it's a form of optimization which
transgresses rungs of the ladder of
emergence sebastian says that our genes
contain the information to make the
structure by controlling a sequence of
events during morphogenesis
our final physical form is merely a kind
of sampled materialization of this lower
level process this is very similar to
this concept of inverse diffusion which
happens in the open ai daily 2 model by
the way
now as sebastian says in his article
deeper neural networks are totally human
engineered whether it's the architecture
itself or indeed the optimization
algorithm which is stochastic gradient
descent given enough data deep learning
algorithms can learn to decompose any
space into a highly sophisticated
geometrically tessellated nested
compressed representation
the problem is that this representation
is extremely brittle and breaks with
even minor changes in the environment
deep learning models efficiently
compress what they have seen before with
laser-like effectiveness but the problem
is that many domains are open-ended and
combinatorially large and are not
amenable to memorization in this way
sebastian argues that using emergence
and self-organization might help
robustify neural networks in a similar
way to how biological systems are robust
although he conceded that
self-organization is not the only
principle that allows biological
organisms to display high-level
robustness anyway i highly recommend you
check out sebastian's article it's
brilliant
to follow up a bit on this idea of
centralized versus decentralized if we
look at decentralized systems not always
but very often they sort of
self-organize into a centralized system
for example the brain has the sort of
the prefrontal cortex directing
everything if we look at humans the
first thing humans do is they band
together and they elect a leader right
um if if we build decentralized
computing systems there's always like
one leader and
so how how much how much do you think
this the emergence
of properties such as intelligence or
whatnot is a property of really
decentralized computing or how how
important is this sort of leader
election among decentralized systems and
can we do without it
oh uh yeah i think that's a great
question again you always ask a great
question so
you're right like in many decentralized
systems like our brain or in
civilization
eventually something like a centralized
system is formed
and and usually maybe via our genotype
our genes the same
centralized system is usually formed
across
all humans and in even societal
structures like this
typically you have a leader
or a few leaders and they govern the
society in a few types of
ways right
but but
i i think the emergence of that
structure is very important compared to
uh designing it uh top down at the
beginning uh let me tell you why uh
because like take the example of of say
our bodies or the brain right there
there are cases like the the the way the
uh the structure is is emerged may be
the same for most people but for people
with certain disabilities of unfortunate
disabilities from from birth or
accidents uh
we're able to see
brains or structures evolve differently
but they they still function as a whole
like like certain certain infants are
known to
to have half their brain and like uh
not functioning at birth and you know
like the the it has to be removed like
uh from birth but they still grow into a
functional brain that has a different
structure than what what we
traditionally know for most humans
and and even for for people with
disabilities like like blindness or
death they eventually
their brain structures would would like
change functionalities a blind person
would use their visual cortex to process
audio for instance so so
where the emergence property is very
useful for
for tackling like changes in the
environments as i mentioned in the
beginning so so ultimately the goal is
to have something that will work even
when the environment changes but
it'll work maybe optimally when the
environment is expected but it's not
going to completely not work when the
environment changes
alexander maude vinsef another guy that
we definitely need to get on the show
wrote a fascinating article called
growing neural cellular automata i've
been looking into this and essentially
it's a convolutional or neural network
type architecture which produces what
appears to be an rgb
value for every single pixel but
actually the output is a 16 channel
space including a bunch of other
information they've turned a
self-healing image generation process
into an emergent phenomena and so
they're kind of continuously applying
this convolutional neural network over
the um input space much like you would
do with the traditional cellular
automata except this one of course is a
continuous cellular automata which is
learned with a neural network
but then it has this incredible thing
where if you interactively delete
components of the image or perturb
components of the image it'll
dynamically repair itself which is
fascinating just imagine some of the
applications for this where you could
have self-healing systems and you could
have these agents that
learn to heal a system as an emergent
behavior
so there's this really interesting
intellectual journey here which starts
with discrete cellular automata which
are binary and run on a regular lattice
which is say a two-dimensional grid and
then all sorts of interesting things
happen when we increase the resolution
or run on different manifolds or have
continuous values and then even use
something like a learnable neural
network for performing the update rules
dr danielle gratarola is a scientist and
postdoctoral researcher at epfl he
recently published a fascinating paper
called learning graph cellular automata
which was published in in eurips and in
that work he focused on a generalized
version of a typical cellular automata
called a graph cellular automata in
which the lattice structure is replaced
by an arbitrary graph uh in particular
they extended the previous work which i
just showed you from alex malvinsef you
know which was when they they
learned a 2d convolutional neural
network for applying um the cellular
automaton update rule to now using a
graph neural network and learning the
update rule on that with message passing
it's absolutely fascinating so now i
give you danielle gratarola cool
right let me get my notes out by the way
i've i've just been on a crash course in
cellular automata oh nice
uh it it is absolutely fascinating yeah
um i'm completely hooked on it actually
yeah it is it is fascinating tim i'm
gonna i i have to share with you i have
to share with you my little uh
cellular tama that that tries to do um
you know uh
light casting or shadow casting
roguelike roguelike games oh nice
yeah many of those like tiny games like
even uh i think it's called gnome
fortress something like that yeah it was
an old-school linux game uh it's used
like celero tamato to generate the
terrain and stuff like that it's super
fast fascinating
yeah i played around with with simple
simple cellular automata quite a bit and
little hobby
yeah you know hobby games or simulations
i mean even the um you know tim that
that uh galton board simulation in our
our video that was a solar automata yeah
i hadn't thought about that of course
yeah it's fascinating i mean and by the
way i mean because you linked
alexander's article um you know he did
the kind of the the 2d gridded cnn
version of uh morphogenesis and i mean
maybe you should just introduce i'll
tell you what
we're we're doing this all wrong uh
daniel why don't you introduce all right
right so uh yeah
so my name is daniel i am currently i
just graduated actually from idcia in
lugano so i'm currently working
at epfl in lausanne so i moved to the
french-speaking part of switzerland
and
so right now i'm working in the domain
of proteins
and my formal training during my phd was
in graph neural networks and
at some point i reached out to
my current
let's say supervisors or pi that were
starting out this project on applying
graph neural networks to the protein
domain in particular protein design
which is like
essentially the inverse problem to alpha
fold if you've heard about alpha fold
recently so alpha false goes from the
sequence of amino acids to the folded
structure and one still open and very
interesting problem is so how to do the
opposite so if i want a particular
structure what is the sequence that
would fall into that structure right and
you would think that having solved one
direction would essentially means you've
solved the other but it's still com
computationally expensive to go over all
possible sequence and try and see if
they fall in the correct state and so
like um there's still like this open
question of uh whether the structure of
a folded protein somehow informs uh the
sequence and as you can if you can
predict one from the other uh and so i'm
working in that whole domain
uh right now but as i said like my
background is in graph neural networks
uh during my phd i've worked on a
thousand different things related to
graph neural networks and by the way i
started like 2017 i started my bhd so it
was still at the time where graph neural
networks were starting to emerge a
little bit so there was like this
feeding frenzy of you know finding
applications and trying to see if stuff
worked which was a really exciting time
to be in graph neural networks i should
say um and then like uh at some point
during my phd towards the end i
i decided to link back to one of my
oldest passions which was this idea of
the cellular automata
and and trying to see if some of the
tools that i have been working on had
been working on would actually be useful
to to say something about that whole
world and it turned out it did so yeah
yeah well i i mean i'm so inspired by
geometric deep learning after i spoke
with michael bronstein and and his
friends um but yeah i mean so much of
the work that we've been brought up on
is is uh
euclidean or gridded data and then when
you start to think about some of the
applications that you can do with graphs
and and you know curved surfaces and so
on it blows my mind but before we get
there why don't we go on a kind of
intellectual journey here and start
talking about cellular automata now
anyone who's had the misfortune of doing
leeco challenges in the tech industry
probably would have had to implement
conway's game of life at some point and
um usually the way you know these
challenges are formulated is and they
are binary which means the cells are one
or zero
and it's on a regular lattice usually a
2d grid and you have a whole bunch of
update rules which are a function of the
neighboring cells and then you just kind
of execute all of these rules and you
just get this emergent phenomena happen
when you zoom out it's fascinating so
can you just tell us a little bit about
about cellular yeah sure so basically
the
the short story is what you just said so
you have this uh essentially it's a
computer program or a computational
model that has a state
and typically the status what you said
it's just a bunch of cells arranged in
these regular structures which can be
you know 1d or 2d or even 3d or whatever
and and then every cell has a particular
state of its own and then you have this
transition rule or update functions
however you want to call it that
is applied synchronously to every cell
and essentially decide what the next
state of the cell will be as a function
of the cell itself and the neighbors um
and really the cool thing that you find
is that even though like the complexity
at the level of the rule is fairly low
so you have pretty simple rules that you
can define um you know the behavior that
emerges can be like very life like like
the the tiny creatures that you see
emerging on this on these grids uh
really
you know they kind of click with with
our pattern matching system as humans
because they they look like uh tiny
creatures moving around the grid they're
able to spawn new creatures they're
they're they're able to you know move
coherently and they add periodicity over
time and and so it's either living
things or or engineered things there
they have the same that kind of
regularity that we that we recognize as
interesting um
and that's like the just the basic
version but then
with time people have started to
complicate the definition of cellular
automata right so for example instead of
you know binary you can ask the question
of okay what happens if i allow the
states to be
n and possible states over the grid so
and i can color the states differently
or i can ask you i can ask what happens
if the state is continuous right
and as you start doing that what you see
is that uh the the behavior becomes more
and more complex in a sense even though
uh let's say the common god of
complexity at the level of the rule
remains fairly low as you start
introducing just that tiny bit more of
complication you see this insanely
complicated patterns that emerge as a
result and so for example at some point
people started uh let's say playing with
the definition of the neighborhood right
so you make it a bit a bit larger so
which is equivalent to increasing the
resolution right so your your grid
approximation which if you think about
it like a grid is just a discretization
of 3d space or 2d space right but at the
same time we are like as humans we are
very far from that kind of level of
discretization of space if it even
exists right so we're we're used to
thinking about high resolution in a
sense and so what you what you observe
if you start to increase the resolution
of these models is that their behavior
starts to become you know eeriely like
living things and so you see like tiny
cells forming and moving around and then
they start to organize into membranes
and stuff like that and this all happens
by that same convolution like process
that's happening on this grid
and and that's why i think they're so
fascinating you know leading back also
to your comment before like they have
this
they let you observe
behaviors that typically you only see in
nature but at the same time you are
aware of this
inherent simplicity that the behavior
stems from
and uh and so i'm already like kind of
diverging because this topic like
automatically makes me go on rants of
how these things are super simple and
yet super complicated and super
fascinating
maybe maybe um
just playing devil's advocate here
because i i too love solar automatize we
were talking about before we started the
show
but just to perhaps pull things back to
some grounding here which is that uh
in a way folks working on cellular
automata have converged in some ways to
a very old
set of numerical techniques called
finite difference
you know modeling right so and
the way what engineers do with finite
difference is they say okay look i have
this set of partial differential
equations right and as we know
tons of things in the world physical
phenomena can be described by pdes
partial differential equations and they
say
okay can't solve these symbolically so
but i can do it numerically if i have a
grid then i can start to write down
how the pdes you know result in changing
continuous values based on kind of
neighboring grid cells and they do this
exact thing they create a mesh
they uh write down what uh what
transition rules the pdes would would
imply for each individual cell
and then you run simulations and so you
wind up with things like
you know uh
the equivalent of cellular automata with
continuous values for the wave equation
or for diffusion equations or for all
this kind of thing and so in one sense
it shouldn't surprise us that
cellular automata can reproduce all the
behaviors that we see
in life because indeed the majority of
that or all of it you know stems from
partial differential equations at some
level and we know that we can
approximate those solutions
with cellular automata via the you know
finite difference route
um but at the same time
it feels it definitely feels mysterious
and i think there is something
something deep there and this even goes
back to say mandelbrot right with his
discovery of
of fractals i mean what the heck i just
had this simple little
quadratic equation in complex space and
if i just iterate that map over and over
again i wind up with this absurdly
complex you know in a sense like
infinitely complex
you know boundary and and interesting
connections
so
there's these kind of two opposing
viewpoints i wonder how you how you
reconcile those like on the one hand it
seems very
interesting and mysterious and yet on
the other hand it seems like of course
if we go to a high enough resolution we
can simulate arbitrary differential
equations i think it's like the i don't
know if it's an answer but one possible
explanation of this apparent dichotomy
is uh it's a matter of scale right so if
you go low enough with the scale and by
low i mean you know modeling uh the low
level physics in a sense uh
you probably get to the point where the
skill is so low that everything makes
sense to be modeled as a continuous
differential equation right
and so at some point you know cellular
automata or a set of pdes what's the
difference it's not even that well
defined like it's like a sort of
spectrum that you can decide where you
want to place yourself in um
what is interesting though is that i
think that
this idea of locality
and and having you know update rules or
transition rules or whatever you know
execution kind of engine you want to
have
for your inherent program
at that point it
it becomes
as you go up in the abstraction
hierarchy it just makes sense to
consider your elements yourselves as
discrete objects and then this is maybe
not true if you are if you're modeling
for example the flow of some some water
or whatever for example i had this
professor uh when i was at the
during the bachelor that he was using
cellular automata to model how water
moves in like inside coffee for example
right and and then you can you can then
you can ask the question of okay is it a
cellular automata should i be using some
something else that is actually
continuous but what i think is really
fascinating about the idea at least of
cas is that as you go up in the
hierarchy then it makes more and more
sense to think about you know discrete
agents interacting according to some
rules and at that point the continuum
like kind of gets lost anyway or at
least it gets lost in the way you want
to model it right so if you're modeling
you know again low-level physics it
makes sense to be working with a grid
but if you're you know working out
modeling human interaction for example
which you can probably still
model fairly well as a sort of local
kind of dynamical system
then it doesn't make sense to model
humans as living on a continuous trade
well no you kind of want to model them
as individual
objects in a sense right
yeah what's what's interesting to me is
as as you're bringing up so you were
going in in this direction of
um
if we're at a very low level it might
make sense to think of of a continuum
but then at some level of abstraction
uh things really behave as these
discrete
you know objects or say in the case of
of carl fristen you know a markov
boundary a thing that has this kind of
stochastic dynamic
you know markup boundary yet it behaves
as a unified you know whole um
and and what's odd is that
neither at the highest scale nor the
lower scale
does either continuity or discrete
nature ever disappear it just seems to
be continuously
i shouldn't have said continuously it
just seems to be forever intertwined you
know that okay if i keep going down in
this direction i get to a continuum but
maybe if i go even deeper i get back to
some discrete you know hypergraph or if
i'm going in the opposite direction i
get up to say the discrete level of
molecules but if i keep going it starts
to behave as a continuous fluid if i go
further it starts to behave as a
discrete cell if i go further than that
it's a you know you keep interleaving
back and forth between discrete being
the correct level of analysis versus
continuous being the correct level
analysis that's kind of the mystery is
that they're they don't exist at either
extreme they just are constantly
interleaved that's the real cool thing
that
it's like it appears very arbitrary that
we as humans at some point decide no
this is like i i recognize this as a
layer of of this abstraction it's like
you know i i can
pretty clearly distinguish between being
at the layer of atoms and being at
layers of cells although if you look
close enough then cells are composed of
proteins and proteins and composites of
atoms so you can kind of always go back
uh but at some point there's there's
also this kind of uh
limit uh that defines um or that decides
how far can a layer kind of communicate
with the other layers right so we as
humans we have no agency to interact
with atoms although we are made of atoms
but we have kind of essentially zero
ability to interact with that layer and
so it's like there is a sort of
intrinsic boundary that lets you operate
on some levels of these obstructions and
these levels appear to be fairly close
to one another so i might be able to
influence the level above me and below
me which might be in i don't know if we
want to look at some discretization
maybe i can act on my organs and i can
act on society right one level that one
level up but already i cannot act on my
proteins right or or my individual cells
it's gonna be much much harder uh and as
you go down in the hierarchy and of
course up in the hierarchy the
contribution of that particular layer
becomes less and less relevant right so
it's like it you you're definitely able
uh
to recognize those boundaries or like i
don't know if you can give a precise
definition but there definitely appears
to be some level of
discreteness uh or at least some ranges
where it makes sense to talk about a
level of abstraction that stands on its
own i would say
yeah i'm really interested actually that
there's a kind of observer relative
problem that you know depending on the
ladder of the um
let's call it an emergence ladder we're
on a rung of the emergence ladder and
maybe that determines how we can
formalize and understand phenomena on
different rungs of the emergent ladder
but just to pull the discussion back a
tiny bit so um this is all quite new to
me and i'm fascinated by it i've
actually just started reading a new kind
of science by wolfram uh inspired by all
the links that that you sent us and um
you know one of the one of the first
things to learn about with cellular
automata is is the basic discrete
one-dimensional version and um wolfram's
actually given all of them names right
because if you think about it in the
one-dimensional discrete cellular
automata you have a neighborhood of
three and then if it's binary you've got
two to the power of three which means
you've got eight patterns and then for
every single pattern it could be one or
zero so you've got two to the power of
eight which is 256 things and and all of
those things you know so for example
there's um rule 110 which he says
exhibits class 4 behavior now this is
interesting as well because i'm
interested in you know did he just pluck
this out of thin air that you can kind
of classify the behavior subjectively of
of phenomena in in the emerging uh
domain
and uh but anyway he said class iv
behavior which is neither completely
random nor completely repetitive
localized structures appear and interact
in various complicated looking ways and
and then there's this guy called matthew
cook who used to work for wolfram and
and he said these structures are rich
enough to support universality all right
this result is interesting because rule
110 apparently is is an extremely simple
one-dimensional system and difficult to
engineer the form specific behavior
anyway so i'm reading wolfram's book and
i'm interested like what's he talking
about you know universal communication
and um he he has he has this wonderful
image where he says oh you know look um
here are the occurrences of
progressively longer blocks than the
pattern generated by rule 30 starting
from a single black cell and as far as
he could tell all of the possible
eventual blocks will appear potentially
letting the pattern serve as a kind of
directory of all possible computations
and that was kind of like his argument
about the the uh touring universality so
what's your take on that uh yeah so
they're definitely fascinating objects
in that regard meaning that so i think
that for rule 110 in particular the
argument there is that you can build
logic gates essentially with them
because you kind of have this and i
might be messing up with the specific uh
you know one of the 256 ones but like at
some point you're you're able to uh
shoot this kind of race in one direction
and another in another direction and at
some point if they interact uh the rays
disappear and if they don't interact uh
the array goes on and so it's like a
zero and a one depending on if the rays
survive or dies um and so like
all the arguments for universality of
these models by the way are not
arguments for their efficiency in doing
computation they're just like you know
showing equivalence
is that you can essentially build the
basic machinery that you would need to
perform computation which is like basic
manipulation like the nand gate and
stuff like that and i think that the
formal proof of computation actually uh
goes in a completely different direction
with a different computational model but
like the general idea is that one right
you can simulate a turing machine just
by encoding the various rules in
essentially the state and that's a very
fascinating thing that i've been
thinking about a lot recently because
uh what's what we see and and much of
the things we can do with cellular
automata
are not necessarily uh given by the rule
itself so the rule is always simple and
in fact uh it's not necessarily new in a
new kind of science but i think in the
next work by wolfram which is the
wolfram physics project uh like he kind
of makes this argument that uh the rules
that govern the universal cellular
automata should be fairly simple right
um and so like there is this bias
towards simple rules but the complexity
that we typically observe comes from the
configuration of the states right and so
all of the computation that you might
want to to do with the cellular automata
comes from configuring the state in the
correct way in fact if you google it up
it should should be fairly easy to find
at some point people uh had this
challenge on stack overflow of
implementing a functional clock in the
game of life as it turns out you can't
implement the functional clock in the
game of life you just need to configure
the states in a particularly smart way
and the state in the states will evolve
on their own and they will create digits
and then change the digits according to
the time once uh every second and so on
uh and so this is like this is what i
find fascinating about the kind of
computation that cas do right because
you can prove that they are universal
because you can do basic operations with
them uh but then much of the complexity
that you can actually observe comes from
the actual states that you have to
configure and that of course is by no
means trivial which is also why people
haven't been using you know cas to
implement computers you use different
architectures and computational models
yeah and and to that point and by the
way so the cook proved rule 110 you know
turning complete by mapping it to
another turing complete system like the
cyclic tag systems
or something i think it was and then and
i think there's only one other rule that
might be
turing complete but it hasn't been
proven you know one way or the other
like rule 30
may or may not be touring complete i
don't think this is quite fascinating
right just this little
simple set of rules and maybe the
simplest turing complete system out
there but as you were just saying the
difficulty lies in going from
a simple set of rules and some complex
initial conditions to then being able to
really predict
what the large-scale behavior is going
to be and i think wolfram you know
points us out himself
which is that um
you know he he has this concept of
computational irreducibility which which
essentially says
look uh predicting what this computation
is going to do
is just as hard as actually running the
computation so there's no shortcuts in a
sense you can't you know and it's
related to to you know
turning completeness you know as well or
rather rather the uh you know the
halting problem which is essentially a
similar kind of problem it says that
trying to compute whether or not a
turing machine an arbitrary turing
machine will halt is just as difficult
as running it itself and therefore you
can't yeah you can't do it without
halting or without failing to halt that
sort of thing um so my question to you
is and this is kind of this emergence
question is
is this just an impossible barrier so in
other words is it the case that you know
something in physical reality runs
runs things you know whether you believe
it's a computation or not whatever
there's some substrate that's executing
this uh you know this this automata of
the universe okay and it just it
displays all this multi-scale behavior
and so you get these emergent you know
things happening human beings planets
you know uh super clusters in the galaxy
whatever
is it
even possible in any
in any sense to predict from
lower levels higher level
emergent behavior or is there just this
barrier
that in a sense this irreducible
complexity that we there's no shortcuts
we can't actually predict
a higher layer of emergence or
abstraction from a lower layer one
without just running the universe itself
a very interesting question and i don't
think i'm really equipped to answer that
without making anybody angry i would say
so that there's a lot of speculation
that you can do
uh
don't worry i've made people angry by
just asking a question so yeah so
what i can say is that so first of all
like we were saying before there seems
to be some some degree of
communication or or ability to predict
what the layer above or below you will
do right so if you are let's say
configuring a cellular automata if we
accept that that is uh how the universe
runs so if you're you're trying to
configure or or to study uh cellular
attack at a particular level you might
have some intuition a priori but what
they will do right so it is possible to
engineer an emergent system if you are
you know even without you know running
it necessarily but you probably can come
up with some smart rules that have a
desired behavior that you might want to
have now it's a much more it's a much
harder question to say
can we build a particular cellular
automata that acts like we see in the
universe and and that's like
because that requires uh us to answer
the question of what are we actually
trying to model and at what scale are we
trying to model the physical reality are
we trying to model you know a brain or a
network of humans right um and and that
i guess uh you can also make that
irreducibility argument for intelligence
in general right so do i necessarily
need to model the brain in order to have
intelligence or can i just approximate
intelligent behaviors and and maybe just
train a neural network to do that right
so i think it's a much more profound
question than just what is the cellular
summary doing and how do i reproduce
that in a computer um it's it's a
question of about like the nature of
reality itself and and whether it's the
only possible way to obtain a particular
computation is to simulate it starting
from the lowest possible level now we
have some evidence that this is not
necessarily the case like we're having
some uh some you know models of
computation that are able to emulate
some of the phenomenas we see right um
and so i guess this is you know it gives
us some kind of hope that
we
might be able to design one such system
and people for example have been started
to using
machine learning to try and design
cellular or someone that do a particular
thing right
so there might be
some degree of approximation that we can
achieve without necessarily computing
everything starting from the lower level
and this is in a sense of course
wolfram's uh physics program i think he
calls it is all about
can we start
at the lowest
possible and i mean like finest scale
you know i don't even know 10 to the
minus 100 meters or something uh
you know substrate in the form of this
this hyper graph and then and then
with these simple rules does the
universe as we know it
you know emerge from that at least on
that that seems to be the uh
you know the case and i mean it or
rather that's that's the that's his
program and
could be could be possible um i think
there's so many open questions there and
of course it's a very active area of
research and almost a new branch of
of mathematics too and i or physics at
least and i think um wolfram himself
said if it can do if it can do these
predictions like for example if we can
derive general relativity or you know
quantum mechanics it's it's at least a
century yeah a century out so
you know we have a while to wait but i'm
curious what you think about
the possibility of that so if it if we
have this interleaved so here's a
question we talked earlier about the
interleaved discrete and continuous you
know that as you move along kind of
scales of emergence or reduction you
keep coming across
the need to either view things as a
continuum or is a is a discrete you know
spectrum of something and so it's like
this alternating series you know in math
that we learned that never converges
right it's plus one minus one it never
converges well if you go to zero so if
you go to that end of infinity all the
way down to the smallest possible scale
do you think we arrive at a discrete
system like a hypergraph like like
wolfram's envisioning or is zero
actually a continuum i'm curious what
you think
that answer is and and what you think
about uh wolfram's paradigm of right so
i think that i was reading about this
some time ago and
the question of whether at the lowest
possible level you actually can see
something like a cell and that kind of
discreteness to it i think it's still an
open question in physics
yeah exactly the atom of space like
that's probably from what i understand
it's still an entirely open question in
physics like they haven't been able to
answer that uh and and the question
there would be like can we actually
discretize the notion of space and the
notion of time because that would be an
answer answering yes to that question
would be a fairly strong argument for
wolf from theory of you know the
universe being this huge l system that's
constantly
rewriting itself right um
but of course it's it's difficult to say
like and at some point one should even
ask a question of whether
for us it's even important to be going
at that particular level which is what
you were asking before like do we
necessarily need to answer the question
of whether the universe is continuous to
be doing interesting things and then
then it becomes like a matter of goals
so
personally i find it fascinating to be
talking about all this localized
emerging computation because i see it as
a potential path forward towards agi for
example right um and and and the
question there at that point becomes can
we achieve something like that without
necessarily needing to go and simulate
the whole universe just to get you know
you simulate this huge
environment just that maybe it will
develop intelligence that seems insanely
costly to do for achieving something
that we can describe fairly well
um and so i i don't know really if at
some point it will become obvious or
people will be able to answer the
question of whether the universe is
continuous
which would probably discredit the
cellular automata theory
uh but i think it's interesting that
this idea of cellular automata
especially how you know wolfram has
instantiated it in one particular way
but the general paradigm is much more
flexible in a sense um
it's interesting that we can describe
things with this model and you know
whatever the level we decide to start at
it we also know that if we set the rules
right then we will be able to observe
the same kinds of emergence and so it
becomes kind of arbitrary to for us to
decide where do we start simulating the
the universe or the system we're trying
to simulate right
yeah
i mean
there are so many things to unpack here
i find that's absolutely fascinating you
know so you know how does our universe
work and you know wolfram was kind of
making the point that underneath all of
this richness and complexity that we see
in physics they could just be really
simple rules
so is the universe an emergent
phenomenon and it kind of see i mean
that's it's very subjective right it's
very vague it seems like it is because
when you recreate so many of these
emergent systems they produce phenomena
that look a lot like the universe right
but then there's this notion of well
could we find the exact simple rules and
the exact representation to create
something like the universe and then
there's this notion of irreducibility
and then it becomes very very vague but
what's fascinating though is just by
applying the the same rules over and
over again you can produce something
that looks really really complicated and
that's just not what our intuition tells
us at all
yeah that's true and i think like i just
had this uh you know kind of follow up
to to the discussion which is this uh
idea that at some point
you're interested in understanding the
universe at some particular scale right
so you you might be interested in
understanding intelligent systems or you
know just living system if you want to
be at one level lower and so at some
point the questions you need to be
asking it goes it goes back to what we
were saying before right you if you if
you're interested in a particular level
you don't necessarily need to go all the
way down and start there you might just
go one level lower and start modeling
things there and know that you maybe
maybe you will introduce some
approximation errors but if you do
things well enough then you will kind of
see that emergence and you can build on
top of that layer of player after layer
right and and and i agree that it is
fascinating that this kind of emergence
appears to be like a sort of constant
throughout the different layers right so
you it doesn't it doesn't really matter
the specific rules that are acting at a
particular layer right it what matters
is that the same kind of computational
engine appears to be working at every
layer and so you might have the similar
phenomena happening at the physics level
or at the cell level or at the society
level and the rules will change and in
fact michael actually makes this very
interesting argument about
different layers being recognizable by
the kind of goals they're trying to
solve right and so for example you might
recognize the a layer the layer of
society because it's
trying to solve the goal i don't know of
of surviving as a species for example um
and the rules that you will find at that
layer will be in a sense
emerging to solve that particular goal
exactly like i don't know in a very
similar simple level atoms will have
very simple rules that just try to
satisfy some electrical or physical
constraints right and so as you move up
and down you will find different rules
but the same computational principle so
i will have a rule that tries to solve
an objective through localized
computation and and that is what i
really find fascinating about cas and
and just the general idea of of this
kind of models because they appear to be
reasonable to explain different layers
in this architecture
and so this is really interesting to me
so so i mean this is getting to um
something we were just previously
talking about with a with our other
guests about um formalizing what happens
in that emergent space and actually when
we speak with ai alignment people they
bring up asimov's laws and you can get
into you know utilitarianism versus
deontological
but um
you know the thing is even because we're
gonna get on to your work when we're
talking about morphogenesis and what's
fascinating there is that actually you
almost want to um evaluate the rules
that you're creating based on the
emergent phenomena and then there's this
thing about how do i how do i formalize
the nature of that phenomenon i mean if
i was steve stephen wolfram for example
how would i formalize universe like
behavior right oh this thing's emerging
and it looks like the uni looks like the
universe how do i formalize that
so yeah i think what you're describing
is
a property that we might find in
different aspects of life right once you
have the same rules applied in an
interconnected system of sort and so
there's like this interconnected graph
of of information flow and how you act
on that on that graph so as you have
that system and and it goes on over time
probably at some point you will see some
emerging phenomena and i guess at that
point the question is how do i control
that emergence like how can i introduce
some sort of metric of my own to try and
understand what's going on and how to
control it which
to which i would answer that it's
impossible to tell a priori like it's so
task dependent and it's so dependent on
what you're doing that
like if you are trying to optimize for
something then you should have
you should go at the level that we were
saying before like you should go at that
level of abstraction and trying to
understand what are your goals at that
point right so it could be that you're
optimizing for the overall success of
the company
or or whatever it is that you're
developing code for right and so you
might introduce that as a higher level
goal
and hope that what's happening at the
lower level
gets optimized to it to essentially
achieve that objective right which
nature has done to selective evolution
but if you're trying to introduce
that signal into your own control
process uh you you might need to to do
some particular actions at the lower
level so that maybe you can achieve that
higher level objective
i know but this is the tyranny of
objectives though right there's the
shortcut rule there's all of these
because as soon as soon as you formalize
something you you block stepping stones
and and you exclude the actual behavior
that might lead you to where you
actually want to go yeah it's
fascinating but um i do want to move on
a little bit i want to kind of slowly
move the conversation towards your work
but i want to go via this fascinating
article that you that you shared with me
about morphogenesis and actually it was
by this guy i think he's at google he's
called alexander maude vincent vince
and the article was called growing
neural cellular automata and it was
performing uh morphogenesis and more for
jet i mean that sounds like a
ridiculously complicated word but it's
about um you know it's essentially how
if i perturb something or if i have some
initial starting state how could i how
could i create something that i want to
uh create right so um this was using a
cellular automata on images on the 2d
plane and he was able to design a
cellular automata and an update rule
which would quickly converge to a
desired image so there was a a picture
of a lizard
and you could you could damage it and
perturb it and then it would it would
just come back to the lizard and
it's just it's it's incredible to me
right because um it's like from these
local low-level rules you could actually
create something that had global
coherence yeah and i've just never seen
anything like that before so um tell me
a bit about that article yeah that's
amazing uh so that article in particular
uh was inspired by uh this idea of the
flat warm which is like a tiny creature
that if you take it you cut it in half
like both halves are able to regrow into
the whole thing like independently and
so the the question there was how can
this animal be doing this like because
you know the decision to grow is a local
decision and the decision to stop must
be a global decision so there must be
something inside the growing process
that's somehow coordinating the global
shape right and and in fact this this
idea of morphogenesis in cellular
automata was already uh present in
literature of course um and people like
had been doing it uh even ten years
priors uh you know trying to generate uh
or to generate like uh flags so you have
like three states uh cellular automata
with uh different colors and you try to
arrange the cells of a particular color
in a particular region of the images
that you can generate like the flag of
italy or the uk or whatever right so you
can kind of uh see that it grows into
that shape um and what they did in that
paper was bringing it to the absolute
next level right so it was looking at
this platform and say okay it's able to
regrow into the full thing okay can we
do the same thing with a neural network
and so can can we learn to do the same
thing because this goes back to probably
what we were saying before which is
designing these kind of rules can be
insanely hard like you don't know what
the rule is that just by letting it
evolve locally on inputs of pixels
it eventually gives you the lizard or
you know they have this smiley emojis
they have different kinds of emotions
and images
and so how do we design that well the
answer in that case was well we'll take
a convolutional neural network which if
you look at it has essentially the exact
same kind of
shape as the cellular automata so it has
like a local three by three kernel uh
that updates the the state of every
pixel uh synchronously so it's like
there's there's a lot of overlap there
and they said okay let's just uh train
this neural network
in a recurrent way so we're just gonna
propagate forward and then use by
propagation through time to adjust the
weights so that after some steps of
computation we land in a particular
object or objective state um
and and so this is this is what they did
and they were able to
to to make this very very robust
actually so they were able to have the
image grow from a single pixel into the
full thing and then you can start trying
to make that robust perturbation so you
put what happens if i cut the image in
half i would like to grow it i would
like it to grow back into the full thing
and you can actually can introduce that
type of input output examples in the
training process and so that's what they
did and then they have this whole
analysis of what the cellular automata
does
or the neural cellular automata does
for example they let it evolve
way past the training horizon that it
they trained it for uh and so they let
it compute over and over and over again
and at some point what happens is that
it breaks the stability and it kind of
starts producing the same pattern
everywhere on the image so it kind of
the single lizard becomes a pattern of
textured lasers everywhere and in fact
they actually have done some really cool
follow-up work where they actually do
the same to actually generate textures
so you can use that instability to
generate textures on an image um which
is very cool and uh and nature like if
you look at the images
well it is possible to because i know
they did a whole bunch of stuff to
robustify it if you like but it is
possible to make it lose its global
coherence so like on the lizard i would
press in the middle of the lizard and if
i kind of oscillate the mouse cursor a
little bit i could make the lizard grow
another pair of legs and feet yeah but
what fascinates me is is that this is i
don't think it was synchronous either i
think they um to make it resemble real
life a little bit more they they formed
the the update rules randomly and and
stochastically but um it's incredible
though isn't it that just by having
essentially what is a filter back i
think it's a bit more complicated than
that they have a notion of if it's
growing and dead and alpha they've got
about 16 different values of are they
not just rgb for every single pixel but
but but basically it's it's a gridded
cnn and you're just updating this thing
and you get an insane amount of global
coherence from these bottom-up rules and
there are loads of people we're speaking
to that that think that ai must be top
down you know it's not possible for it
to be bottom-up but but this is this is
fascinating right it is it is and so one
thing that i find fascinating is that
there is absolutely no reason why this
should work like at all there is nothing
that we can observe that says that these
kinds of rules should exist at all this
this model in principle is it's like
it's too simple for it to actually work
but in fact it turns out that these
models that these cnns in particular uh
and then in like in my own work we
proved it for for genetic graphs but
like these are universal models so if
there is some kind of computation that
can be expressed in the cellular somata
and like you know by extension as a gnn
as a cnn
then the cnn can implement that
computation and i think that it is
really fascinating that this computation
exists so what what this paper answers
to me is it's not the question of
whether can we do it with a cnn but the
really fascinating thing is that yes
this can be expressed as a process that
you know iteratively and locally kind of
grows the image into what we want and
that's a real fascinating thing like
that
they were able like to actually do this
at all and it is not at all obvious that
they could and but yeah they could do it
yeah
i think the important thing for the
listeners to know is that
yes it has this the small grid which is
its input however the cellular automata
is absolutely not the simple rules you
know that we're used to right like it's
actually a
a a relatively deep
you know neural network behind that
taking a look at that input deciding you
know what to do is that correct oh yeah
i mean it depends on what stream by
complexity like i i would say that you
know being able to compress the
information of the image into you know a
relatively small kernel of a cnn it's
still a
fairly simple way of doing it right so
maybe it's not as simple as you would
have the game of life so you still have
several thousands or probably even
millions of parameters in that neural
network but it's still like it's
encoding a lot of information and
especially what's fascinating to me it's
not that it's just like outputting the
image one shot which of course you know
there would be better better ways to do
it but the fact that it's doing it like
iteratively
like this is a process that by you know
by applying the same rule at every pixel
and doing it doing so iteratively it's
able to output the image and so this is
what i think is really fascinating
yeah so i agree with that i'm just i'm
just trying to set a baseline here so
one thing for the listeners to
understand is that
there is this quite complicated you know
neural network that's looking at the
small window and then deciding you know
how to update so it isn't old-school
cellular automata that have like update
rules that can be written down in three
lines
or something okay and then the other
thing that that very much interests me
about this project in particular is
you know i get on this soapbox pretty
often okay that uh
a neural network as it's typically
conceived which is a neural network
takes you know some some inputs
and it does what is ultimately
equivalent to you can always unroll it
as a forward pass through a fixed depth
you know
uh thing and then you get an output
by itself is not turning complete that
what you need is the ability to do this
iterative
you know computation if you will on kind
of a working space
and that's exactly what we have you know
in this work is there's this plane
and it and it's it's learned this uh
computation that if it gets iterated
over and over again can do very
fascinating things and so i think it's
just important for everyone to
understand that without that iterative
capability without that kind of working
space without that temporal dynamics
you know you don't get this kind of
behavior no exactly exactly and that's
that's exactly what happens right and
like for people working in the gnn
community this would be much more
trivial to to see but like what's
happening is that by recurrently feeding
the output back into as input
into the network
what's happening is that every cell
essentially is able to see farther and
farther away from itself right because
like the receptive field in a sense
aggregates information from the
neighborhood but then so is doing every
other receptive field of every other
cell so after two iteration you will
have reached like a neighborhood of size
i guess four by four instead of three by
three uh and and so you you go on
growing like and this is exactly what
we're doing rough neural networks like
every layer lets you go one step further
and so what's happening with this
iterative computation is that as the
iteration progresses progresses uh every
cell gets access to essentially a more
and more large view of the of the world
system and at some point this
information kind of bounces around like
waves in a pond if you if you think
about it and um
and and it comes back at some point but
that but that's the key but that's the
key right there is at some point and the
problem is that with with irreducible
computations
you don't know at what point that is and
so this t this t parameter is open-ended
the only thing you can do is sit there
computing computing computing that's why
it can never be compressed into any
fixed number of layers it's like you
have to have this open-ended you know t
you have to have an open-ended number of
layers yeah i wanted to unpack this sort
of as well because that there's
something magic about this and it's
exactly as keith said right you know
people even say consciousness itself
what what's emergent and magical about
it is it's reflexive property the fact
that it's constantly going random random
circles and when we look at this
cellular automata even this gridded cnn
version it appears very lifelike and
that's and that's why because we used to
think that neural networks were kind of
like performing iterative computations
and now based on our conversation with
randall balestrurio we know that
actually they're just decomposing the
euclidean space up into these kind of
polytopes and and the amount of
computation is finite so it's a
completely different type of computation
but um
anyway i i wanted to move the the
discussion on to your work danielle so
we've we've we've discussed these um
gridded um uh cellular automata with
with cnns and then graph neural networks
are absolutely fascinating because they
they extend the notion of a cnn into
this world where you can have um any
structure at all so you know the the
concept of message passing for example
it extends the cnn right so you still
have this notion of a neighborhood but
you're not on this gridded plane or
manifold anymore and
you've done exactly the same thing right
you've done this morphogenesis but um
with a point cloud so can you tell us
about that it's absolutely amazing
yeah it was fun because so that whole
paper was about exploring this this very
idea of can we come like people have
been complicating everything about cas
and at some point the question becomes
can you complicate the underlying
geometry and you get the graph cellular
what's on myself um and and then like we
were trying to show that actually graph
neural networks are universal engines to
perform this kind of computation on on
gcas uh and so the task at that point
became like okay can we do more for
genesis on a graph what does it look
like on a graph right then and let's say
the typical visualizable example on the
graph is to take
is to take something that somehow
represents space something that we are
used to interact with as humans uh and
and so this was the point cloud so
points in in space um and we took
several of them we took like this bunny
like thing we took a graph that more or
less represented a writing so some some
letters so something that has like a
spatial kind of notion to it oh and we
were trying to ask the question of like
we were saying before does a rule exist
that starting from a random
configuration of points actually morphs
and and feel like the shape is actually
a real shape if you think about it so
morphs these points into this coherent
shape and and again the cool thing is
that this must happen just through sheer
local message passing so every node at
some point will read the neighbors will
read where it is at that point and we
will decide where to go next and just by
this continuous exchange of information
which at some point again bounces around
to the graph and by the way we have
evidence that no many not not many steps
are needed for this kind of information
to bounce around what you what you
really need is that you at least need to
have as many exchanges as the diameter
of the graph meaning the the most
distance that you have between any two
pair of nodes um
and so like if you can do that at which
what you see is that in fact there
exists a rule that takes you from random
points to bonnie
and it gets there you know fairly stably
as well you can train it to be fairly
stable and so for example what we saw is
that uh because if you think about it
there are like these two regimes that
the neural network must learn right so
it must learn to go from random to bunny
and then from bonnie to bunny so it has
to remain stable once it gets there
right which is what you try to do with
the lizard like you would like the
lizard to remain a lizard even if you
perturb it and the same applies here you
would like the bunny to remain a bunny
even if you perturb it
and so once it gets to the bunny it has
to stay to the bunny
and what you see is that in fact the
network is able to uh you know very
quickly put everything where it's
supposed to be almost immediately like
in two or three steps you know the
random point cloud becomes essentially a
bunny and then it learns to gradually
adjust the remaining points and it is
fascinating that everything is happening
as a as the same rule gets applied
everywhere uh and so we kind of explored
that and uh
it worked fairly well although sometimes
like we had this weird effect that you
probably get as you train a recurring
neural network in the dynamical system
where
so instead of like converging
immediately uh it starts oscillating
around the bunny or around whatever
target you have
and it does this weird oscillations
where it goes from bunny to random to
binding to random and so on forever
and it's really fun when you animate it
because like it looks like the bunny is
stomping on the ground because there is
this weird oscillation on the foot
uh so nice it was really it was really
nice to to work in that uh in that space
amazing i mean in in a way this is an
entirely new as i know you got the work
published in europe's which i think
should give an indication of how
impactful it is but you know you can
think of it as an entirely new model of
computation in a way i mean you said in
the paper that you could apply it to
things like swarm optimization and
control and modeling uh epidemiological
transmission and even improve our
understanding of complex biological
systems in the brain right yeah forget
all that i'm just looking for a
first-person shooter where i'm playing
in a in a world that's just a cellular
automata that self-repairs anytime
somebody does damage to it
yeah you can do that type of stuff like
that that's the cool thing about this is
that once you break free from from the
grid in a sense you're like every time
you have this kind of local interaction
and the cool thing is that the
interaction can signify anything at that
point like it doesn't need to be a
discrete projection of 3d space anymore
which is what did what the image is like
you project the 3d world on the 2d plane
and then you discretize that so it can
be anything it can be you know relations
between humans it can it can be relation
between neurons and whatever is like
doing this kind of
computation through local exchanges in
in whatever geometry of the cells you
want to have
and by the way one thing it also tested
was the setting of the dynamical graph
so a setting in which the graph changes
at every iteration if you want and so
all of that like kind of unlocks a lot
of possibilities because now what you
have is that again if you can't specify
the correct objectives which not
necessarily use it's not something you
can do always or you don't know always
how to do it but if you can
and and if everything turns out to be
differentiable which is another probably
big limitation um then you can train
this object kind of end to end to give
you the desired behavior
right if it is yeah
is that the idea with the so with the
protein
uh protein modeling or synthesis you
know trying to find the dna sequence
that ultimately will give you the
desired protein structure what's the
connection there uh so the connection is
that there is no real connection so far
like i'm not trying to apply this type
of computation onto the protein design
problem
because it introduces like an extra
layer of complexity that i don't think
we're quite there yet to be able to use
this gca stuff reliably to solve any
kind of problem and i'm not even
entirely sure that
any function should be expressed as this
sort of recurrent computation on graphs
so what we're doing with the protein
design is is just trying to solve
different kinds of sub problems which is
for example uh what function should the
protein have and what does that look
like in terms of structure
and once i have the structure what does
the sequence look like so there is no
idea of like
recurrent computation in that space
but in a sense like it's it's similar in
that
you could say you're trying to find
let's say a description for something or
for some for something that has a higher
level behavior uh but in that regard
like this the ca stuff kind of lives on
its own for now i'm hoping that we'll
eventually apply it to you know modeling
protein dynamics or something like that
well what i'm curious about is suppose
uh because the problem of protein
folding itself is is obviously difficult
but suppose
you could design a cellular automata
that could take as input
a dna sequence and then it the some type
of relatively simple
you know
input range on the dna and then it could
run run run iterate and give you
the folded protein as a result
then if that cellular automata was
actually invertible
you could run the reverse computation to
get back to a possible sequence that
would have given you that is there
research into invertible cellular
automata of this nature
okay so let's let's unpack that because
so there are two things uh the first is
that alpha fold actually kind of works
like that meaning that uh it has this
refinement procedure meaning that it
predicts the structure and then it kind
of feeds it back and then tries to
iterate on this on this predicted
structure um
and there is also work uh on reversible
cellular samasa although uh i have yet
to hear uh about reversible neural
cellular
because that would uh imply reversible
you know your neural network and that
required the whole thing to be
integrated essentially right um
but so yeah what would you say is
probably a possible way to do it uh what
i'm wondering if it's you know the best
way to solve the problem because at some
point what i came to realize working so
i had i had the luck to work with many
uh you know
real scientists in a sense meaning
people that actually work with you know
the brain or biology and then people
that actually have a deep biological
biological knowledge um and what i came
to realize is that at some point it
becomes a matter of solving the problem
so it's like solving the problem is more
important than the way you solve it in a
sense right and so if you're trying to
solve protein design
it feels like an exercise in style to
try and do it with a cellular automata
for example because you don't have like
any strong evidence that the the
function that goes from structure to
sequence is actually one one such
recurrent kind of computation that you
need to do
and so at this point like what we're
trying to do
and this is actually like something that
i've tried to force myself to do because
it can become difficult at times is to
not try and use the big guns immediately
so you kind of want to step back and go
back to basics and you know start from a
multiplayer perception and see what what
it does and see if it can actually work
um and try to you know solve the problem
actually solve the problem so you start
simple and you you know stress your
neural network until you until you hit a
wall and once you've hit that wall then
you try and make them a little more
complicated and you try and see if you
know different things could work and i'm
i'm seeing that
that's probably a good way to approach
this this problem so right now
multiplayer perceptions are the way to
go
well wait have you have you taken it one
step further towards simplicity and said
let's start with a linear model and uh
oh right
then
yeah no but you see that that that's
when
sometimes you already know that some
models are not good right because the
thing that i'm trying to do is like
highly non-linear and so like a linear
model probably wouldn't work you can try
even i mean
you can try and you should try probably
but you know it won't work what i'm
talking about is whether you know you
already need to go and look at that
structural source of information do you
need the graph immediately or can you
solve the problem let's say from the
sequence or from you know just the
coordinates without without the graph
representation and so that's what we've
been doing a lot in this in this proton
design space
which as i said is kind of orthogonal to
the work on uh on cellular automata
because like with cellular automata the
question is whether this computation
exists if i can formulate the objectives
can i find the solution with a neural
network like it's a different set of
questions and they're more like
i i don't want to say essential but like
they're at a more basic level than just
you know trying to actually solve a
problem it's more asking questions about
the universe or this particular
computational model and see if the there
are answers
right
yeah
that this whole thing blows my mind i've
only i mean i'm i've only just
discovered this and um from an
engineering point of view i'm fascinated
by this notion of having systems that
can be self-healing
in some sense or even having multiple
agents that are going around my system
and kind of repairing things that get
broken by people
so i guess i mean we'll slowly rap but i
wanted to um
if there are folks that are interested
in some of these topics we've spoken
about so complex systems theory um you
know things like uh craft neural
networks and so on and the work you're
doing
where should they look and also i'm
interested just to know personally what
other areas are you interested in
right uh so as
far as resources go uh
you you can approach it at different
levels so uh if you just want to learn
about cellular automata there's tons of
resources out there and what i would
suggest people do is that they go and
look on twitter which is weird as it may
sound is where like the actual hacker
community is is doing this type of
insanely complex
cellular automata that really have like
once you see them you it's really hard
to to think about them being automata
because the behavior is just so complex
and lifelike and so sometimes you will
find you know some some of these hackers
in this community that
that showed you know their center
automata and then you know side by side
comparison with the real world living
system and they're exactly the same
moving in the same way and it's like
okay so is the ca predicting what's
happening in biology like what what does
that tell you about the nature of the
world and so yeah so i think for the
record i think you may be the first
guest
that's recommended twitter yeah but but
that's the reason for that i love it
that's awesome that's what it is like as
as weird as un unscientific as it may
sound that's that's where interesting
things are happening like you know
twitter is the new archive huh yeah
twitter is the new archive and github is
a new archive like you will find you
know bleeding edge cellular automata on
github you don't necessarily see them
published at all
right now like uh we are starting to see
this ncaa stuff popping up on you know
in europe's icml aclr and it's like
starting to make a breakthrough but you
know it's more there's tim there's hope
for us so you and i may yeah become
researchers
yeah and if you're let's say if you're
interested in more
uh academic work uh especially on the
biology side there is the work of the
entire lab of michael 11 um
and
and it's like
he does a lot of work um
regarding studying emergence in real
biological systems
um and so it's like uh they study uh the
cells of frogs and they
they take cells out of frogs and see
what they do in the different
environment and they were able to create
this like small biological robots
that essentially grow out of skin cells
to create what they call these xenobots
and and that whole group and by the way
uh he is also um part of the that uh
morphogenesis paper with cnn's um and so
like that that whole group is uh is
doing excellent work in that regard i
would say they are the pioneers of this
entire idea of emergence i discovered a
youtube channel called emergent garden
and it's by a guy called max robinson
and he's got some really cool videos
um
i definitely recommend you guys check
that out right okay but does he have a
twitter feed because that's the real
point
you can also keep an eye out as i said
like papers are starting to pop up in
terms of and and this is all in terms of
neural cellular automata if you look at
the literature on cellular automata on
their own like there's a whole bunch of
literature that goes back to the 60s so
like
any kind of variation on the theme has
been explored and proposed and
even for graphs
um and so like right now we're starting
to see this convergence between neural
and uh and cellular in a sense
but
there's tons of literature in
in that whole space uh if you just
approach it from a perspective of
dynamical systems
and and you can see actually really
interesting things so tim before was
asking me about um
this idea clustering the behavior of
rules uh according to you know plus one
plus two plus three plus four and as it
turns out there are pretty clear entropy
measures that naturally cluster the
behavior of rules uh according to their
you know abstract uh behavior and so
like it's uh it's really fascinating
stuff
and you can really see the class four
rules actually have their own space in
this in the center in this entropy
description um so yeah it's um there's a
lot of things you can look into
uh but yeah twitter all the way man if
you if you want to see nice nice images
that's that's where you go
fascinating yeah i mean on the entropy
thing i'm sure carl fristen and even
people like um kenneth stanley you know
the people that study artificial life
they think of um life like uh i don't
know if agents is the right way to do it
but you know the information
accumulation is something that's super
important for for uh the characteristics
of of intelligence and
one one fascinating concept is um the
edge of chaos uh and the work by langton
for example and and that's also
something that pops up continuously in
uh in the right time whatsoever
and elsewhere that's all oh yeah sure
sure sure
well dr danielle uh greta rolla it's
been an absolute honour this has been a
really fascinating conversation actually
i think we need to do loads more content
on on this area this feels like an area
that we've just not really done done
enough on so yeah this has been amazing
thank you so much thank you very much
for having me it was a real honor oh
thank you pleasure
remember to like comment and subscribe
we love reading your comments i really
hope you've enjoyed this episode if you
don't mind please rate us 5 stars on the
apple podcasts app and we'll see you
back
next week